mir aus Berlin zugeschaltet ist jetzt
die Abgeordnete der Linken Sahra
Wagenknecht guten Abend Frau Wagenknecht
guten Abend was halten Sie von der
Entscheidung der Bundesregierung Leopard
2 Panzer in die Ukraine zu liefern und
auch der Erlaubnis an andere Länder die
diese Panzer haben
also ich halte das für hochgefährlich
und ich habe wirklich Sorge
was ja Scholz wahrscheinlich zunächst
auch umgetrieben hat dass man durch
solche Entscheidungen diesen Krieg immer
mehr eskaliert und ich finde es
entsetzlich dass wir nur noch in dieser
militärischen Logik denken also wenn ich
höre dass ernsthafte Militär ist wie der
generalstaatschef der USA also der
oberste Militär der USA generell hat in
Rammstein noch mal gesagt die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass die Russen die
gesamte Ukraine erobern sei gleich Null
aber umgekehrt die Wahrscheinlichkeit
dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg
militärisch gewinnen kann dieser auch
extrem gering und deswegen müssen man
jetzt doch zu Verhandlungen kommen nur
durch Verhandlung lässt sich dieser
Krieg beenden stattdessen liefern wir
immer mehr Waffen immer mehr auch
Angriffswaffen jetzt die schweren Panzer
die Ukraine fordern inzwischen schon
Flugzeuge Schiffe vieles andere mehr wir
lassen uns immer tiefer in diesen Krieg
hineinziehen und ich finde das ist eine
völlig falsche Antwort auf die Situation
wenn Sie wie viele in ihrer Partei auch
Friedensverhandlungen fordern wie muss
man sich das denn vorstellen sehen Sie
denn da die Voraussetzungen auch gegeben
in Russland
ja man muss ja ein Angebot machen und
dann muss man zusehen dass man beide
Seiten unter Druck setzt dieses Angebot
anzunehmen aber bisher gibt es ja von
westlicher Seite weder von den USA noch
von den europäischen Regierungen einen
Druck Friedensverhandlungen einzuleiten
und auch ein Angebot zum Beispiel
bestimmte Konflikte erst einmal
auszusparen um einen Waffenstillstand zu
erreichen das hat ja schon mal im am
Anfang dieses Jahres also als der Krieg
begonnen hatte gab es Verhandlungen ist
dann wohl die sind sogar relativ weit
gewesen es war fast so dass man sich
geeinigt hat hatte Neutralität der
Ukraine gegen russischen Rückzug dann
haben die Ukraine diese Verhandlungen
abgebrochen seitdem geht das Sterben
weiter wir haben faktisch auf dem auf
dem Gefechtsfeld eine patzsituation
keine Seite kann gewinnen also muss es
Druck geben in Richtung Verhandlungen
aber jetzt zu sagen wir liefern immer
mehr Waffen wir liefern vor allem auch
Waffen wo wir die Ukraine ausbilden
müssen wo wir selbst dann als Ausbilder
das hat ja der wissenschaftliche des
Bundestages festgestellt eigentlich
schon als Kriegspartei agieren also wenn
man Soldaten ausbildet ist man Teil des
Krieges und wir werden möglicherweise in
diesen Krieg wirklich hineingezogen das
halte ich für unverantwortlich und
deswegen denke ich das war eine Grund
falsche Entscheidung und ich hoffe immer
noch dass die deutsche Regierung mit der
französischen mit anderen europäischen
Regierung gemeinsam doch öffentlich auch
die USA auffordert jetzt nicht mehr auf
weitere militärische Eskalation zu
setzen die USA ist weit weg aber uns
betrifft es unmittelbar sondern wirklich
ein diplomatischen Weg zu gehen
wenn ich ihnen zuhöre dann höre ich dass
sie möchten dass man Druck ausübt auf
die Ukraine auf Russland auf die Kriegs
auf die Krieg führenden Parteien aber
die Ukraine als überfallenes Land auch
als Opfer hat daran ja gar kein
Interesse die merken ja ganz ganz
anderes und die Ukraine sind ja
diejenigen die um Waffen bitten es ist
ja nicht so als würde würden die USA
oder als würden Deutschland einfach
Waffen liefern aus eigenem Antrieb
übergehen sie nicht die Ukraine wenn sie
sagen man muss Druck ausüben also ich
glaube dass ich die meisten Menschen in
der Ukraine vor allem eines wünschen und
das ist Frieden das ist ein
Waffenstillstand ist ein Ende dieses
Leids dieses Sterbens mir schreiben auch
Ukraine die z.B in Deutschland sind die
sagen sie haben Angst um ihre Männer die
dürfen ja gar nicht fliegen die müssen
ja in dem Land bleiben müssen eventuell
auch in an die Front es sterben jeden
Tag hunderte Soldaten auf beiden Seiten
und selensky hat aber die
Seiten aber es sterben ja nur Zivilisten
auf ukrainischer Seite also es ist ja
kein kein Krieg der irgendwie fair
gefühlt wird
naja es sterben Zivilisten im dornbass
es sterben Zivilisten natürlich auch in
den Gebieten also wo jetzt die Kämpfe
stattfinden aber gerade deswegen gibt es
doch eine Verantwortung diesen Krieg zu
beenden und mit immer mehr Waffen
beendet man keinen Krieg und selensky
hat zurzeit die Position dass er sagt er
will erst verhandeln wenn der letzte
Russe von der Krim vertrieben ist und
deshalb ich für eine völlig
unrealistische Strategie also das kann
man zwar moralisch rechtfertigen aber es
ist unrealistisch man wird die Russen
sicherlich nicht militärisch dazu
bringen die Krim zu räumen und deswegen
wünsche ich mir realistische Ziele und
ich finde auch der Westen auch
Deutschland sollte doch einmal deutlich
sagen was unterstützen wir ein
Kriegszielen aber was unterstützen mir
auch nicht wollen wir dass die Leopards
jetzt auch ein Angriff auf die Krimi mit
unter unterstützen auf die russischen
Stellungen dort da muss man einfach
wissen die Schwarzmeerflotte ist nicht
seit
2017/2014 dort ist seit dem 18
Jahrhundert dort und die wird auch
sicherlich nicht ohne eine unglaubliche
Eskalation sich dort zurückziehen also
ich finde man muss doch irgendwie auch
mal Kriegsziele oder überhaupt Ziele
definieren worauf soll das hinauslaufen
wo soll das enden und da hat auch Herr
Scholz heute nichts dazu gesagt
die Abgeordnete der Linken Sarah
Wagenknecht vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit
sehr gerne